Let's start by finding the degree of each term in either polynomial. So I'll go
ahead and do that right now. Once we figure out the degree of each term in
either expression, we rearrange those terms that the term with the highest
degree comes first and then the rest of the terms go in order of decreasing
degree. So for this top polynomial, we'll need the terms to go in order of
degree from 3 to 2 to 1 to 0. So that's going to give us 32x cubed minus 16x
squared minus 7x plus 12. We can do the same thing for the second polynomial.
Written in standard form, this polynomial is negative 12x to the 7th plus 3x
squared plus 64x. X. Now that we have them written in this way, we can see right
off the bat that this top polynomial is a third degree polynomial and this
bottom one is a seventh degree one. So, standard form definitely makes our job
easier. Remember that standard form is something that applies to all
polynomials, not just ones with single variables or ones with just x's. You'll
get more practice with other polynomials in standard form later.